♪♪
-Okay, so it's 8:30
in the morning.
Why am I awake?
I sort of unexpectedly started
writing an album,
and I just felt really inspired
and I went with it.
And I recorded an entire album
with The Roots remotely.
♪♪
Cheers!
This is so wild!
You know,
when lockdown first started,
I heard Taylor
was writing songs,
and I thought
I was feeling inspired too,
so maybe I should
write some music.
I remember I called you, Tariq,
and I asked if you'd help me.
And you said --
-"Only if you pay me
a lot of money."
-Exactly.
And, Quest, I texted you,
and I said,
"Hey, do you want to work on
something together?"
And you said --
-"How did you get this number?"
-Yeah, but actually,
I was getting pretty bored,
so I said, "Okay."
-It's just a lot of the themes
in my songs
are hard to talk about.
But I know other people
are probably
going through the same things.
-Yeah.
-So maybe the music will
resonate with them.
♪♪
♪ Everybody stared at me ♪
♪ This moment
didn't have to be ♪
♪ But I had too many iced teas ♪
♪ And I peed my pants
in an Applebee's ♪
♪ I said, "Where's the bathroom,
please?" ♪
♪ The waiters all
laughed at me ♪
♪ I ruined my best pair
of khakis ♪
♪ When I peed my pants
in an Applebee's ♪
♪ It's not all good
in the neighborhood ♪
-This next track, when you sent
me the lyrics, I was...
man, I was blown away.
I think this may be one of the
best songs you've ever written.
-It was a different side of you
that I really never seen before.
It was -- It was different.
-Thank you. Thank you.
♪♪
♪ There's almond and soy ♪
♪ Skim and two percent ♪
♪ Coconut and rice ♪
♪ Cashew, oat, and hemp ♪
♪ But I want you, darlin' ♪
♪ Deep in my soul ♪
♪ You're the only milk
that makes me ♪
♪ Whole ♪
♪ I prefer whole milk
over other milks ♪
♪ Yeah, my favorite milk
is def whole milk ♪
♪ It's chock full of vitamin D ♪
♪ It's the only milk for me ♪
-You know, in general,
with this album,
I love how honest
you were with your lyrics.
-I felt like I was
in quarantine with you.
-I was just inspired by
the communal experience
that we're all having.
Alone, but together.
Together, but alone.
-Damn.
That's deep.
♪♪
♪ -Well, I got
a sourdough starter ♪
♪ Added 200 milligrams
of water ♪
♪ I put it in the oven,
350-degree lovin' ♪
♪ And watched it rise ♪
♪ I offered you my first loaf ♪
♪ You just stared back at me
and said nope ♪
♪ But I followed the recipe ♪
♪ I know you say
you're gluten-free ♪
♪ I ate that bread as I cried ♪
♪ You broke my sourdough heart ♪
♪ Yeah, you broke
my sourdough heart ♪
Yeah, you know, I was home with
my two young daughters 24/7,
and even that gave me
some ideas.
So I felt a real connection to
this next song,
and I wanted to do a duet with
Chris Martin.
And I didn't think
he would ever do it.
But we reached out to his team
and, incredibly, he said yes.
-Three, two, one.
♪ -Fuzzy Wuzzy was a bear ♪
♪ Fuzzy Wuzzy had no hair ♪
♪ Fuzzy Wuzzy wasn't very fuzzy,
was he? ♪
♪ -Fuzzy Wuzzy was a bear ♪
♪ Fuzzy Wuzzy had no hair ♪
♪ Fuzzy Wuzzy wasn't very fuzzy,
was he? ♪
♪ -Fuzzy Wuzzy was a bear ♪
♪ Fuzzy Wuzzy had no hair ♪
♪ Fuzzy Wuzzy wasn't very fuzzy,
was he? ♪
♪♪
-It's just so amazing what we've
managed to put together.
-Yeah, I'm excited for this
documentary to come out too.
-What documentary?
-Isn't this going to Disney+
like Taylor's?
-Oh, no, Disney+ didn't want it.
Neither did Netflix, Hulu,
Amazon, Peacock.
-Peacock said no?!
-I know.
Not great.
But look, it's fine.
We're not Taylor.
You know,
she's a musical genius.
We can't do what she did,
but we can still be proud.
We made something beautiful.
We made something real
and honest and from the heart.
Quest?
Tariq?
Guys?
♪♪
♪ I peed my pants
in an Applebee's ♪